VR should be accessible to everyone.
Because it has the potential to let everyone
explore, play, and create in amazing new ways.
But right now, VR is pretty complicated.
To make awesome VR stuff,
developers might have to
learn a new language,
and then spend a bunch
more time to make that stuff
work on multiple headsets.
And then, when we want to play
with their awesome VR stuff,
we’ve got to have the right headset.
VR should be easier.
So developers can make something
quickly and share it with everyone,
no matter what device they’re on.
Kind of like how easy it is to
share stuff on the web, but with VR.
Well, that’s the idea behind WebVR.
It’s VR. On the web. For everyone.
Here’s how it works.
Say you’re in a browser like Chrome,
and you come across a WebVR experience.
You just tap the link, put on
a headset, and boom, you’re in VR.
Developers can build WebVR things
the same way they build web things -
with JavaScript.
And since it all works in a browser,
it’s easy to make it work
for all kinds of VR devices.
Whether it's someone using their phone,
their computer, or their entire room.
Developers are already building and
sharing awesome stuff with WebVR.
We’ve started showcasing their work
on a site called WebVR Experiments.
It gives you a glimpse into
the kind of stuff that’s possible.
You can play simple games.
See the world in a new way.
Explore interactive stories.
Play with a friend.
Or, lots of friends.
Each experiment comes with open-source
code to help others to make new experiments.
And, developers can submit what they make.
All of this is an effort to
make VR more accessible,
so anyone can build and everyone
can play with awesome VR stuff.
So come and start playing
at webvrexperiments.com